some interesting people are gemini's
biggie tupac
angelina jolie johnny deb john f kennedy
marilyn monroe are gemini's typically
known for being very creative
what they're known for is argumentation
they love to take the opposite side of
any conversation the chart
does not tell you that you have to do
this
you have free will you can either
develop yourself
what the chart says this is the best way
through a process of
growth and development are you someone
who believes in god to me
god is the cosmos we're living in god
it's important for people to use
astrology for what it's worth
it's a guide it is not a directive you
know you read in the bible
that we are made in the image of god
it's too human
it's too vindictive it wants to punish
you if you do something wrong
there's nothing about learning except to
obey obey okay it's not so much about
you succeeding or not succeeding
it's about being the best you that you
can be
[Music]
so my guest today you know some of you
guys may say pat what is it with you in
astrology well you know for the longest
time i ran an insurance company i've got
18 19 000 licensed agents and
every time i meet people i ask them
when's your birthday when's your
birthday when's your birthday when's
your birthday
and in my mind i'm trying to figure out
if there's a formula for it so mario
said pat since you always
ask everybody about their birthdays
let's go get somebody who can educate us
a little bit more and see if there's
some credibility behind this astrology
and today
my guest ray couture has been an
astrologist for nearly 50 years there's
an interview with him where i think 14
15 people come up
and by talking to them for like a minute
he has to guess what they what sign it
is and that video got 14 million views
on
cut channel if you've not seen it we'll
put the link below as well but with that
being said
ray thank you so much for being a guest
on valuetainment uh thanks for having me
appreciate being here
yes so so ray what what gets you to wake
up one day and says i want to be an
astrologist how does that happen
well we share a certain common uh
background
i was in the military for quite a while
and um you know uh after i got out of
the military it was kind of like a weird
place you know
you know what it feels like you
discharged and you're
out there trying to figure out well how
do people in the real world work you
know
so i i uh ended up uh
in a coffee house someplace after i got
discharged and i met this guy
and he started telling me more about
myself than water no
we did it he said astrology i looked at
him and i said man you got to be crazy
i've been you know been pushed around by
government regulations back and forth to
co this way and uh some of you know all
of that kind of stuff i don't want to be
pushed around by
balls of gas and rocks in the sky
telling me how to live my life and he
says
well okay fine you don't want to do it
well here's the here's the kick
this was a coffee house and this guy was
surrounded by beautiful young women
and after a while i said to myself you
know i got to get in on that because
he's got something going
i on headed to table and i noticed that
everybody was really interested in
astrology so
uh here and there i would say a few dumb
things you know
and he said hey man i'm going to give
you a list of books you go get them and
we'll work together
i looked at him i said you're crazy
enough to be right
so i went and did that and within a
couple of years we were teaching classes
together
wow and i i view him uh as the person
who gave me the opportunity to take it
from the sky put it in
everyday language people's uh way of
living and understanding
in common ways rather than some big
esoteric kind of
place you know astrology is a real thing
he said look
people think astrology is all about
what's out there you know the big
you're in it you're a part of it you're
a product of it
so he taught me how to do that and then
i got involved with people
who were um pretty much uh the leaders
in
in the astrological community for many
many years
and uh got into radio did an awful lot
of that kind of stuff and did
astrological work from there so that
that's how i got started
very interesting on on and how does that
become a career is it just teaching
courses i mean how
how do you monetize that career as an
astrologist
well you know my focus uh was not
so much on monetized my focus was
on what in the world was going on
and how could i figure out what it was
because i felt
over time after learning more and more
about my own astrological configuration
that i needed to be uh providing service
and the service i needed to provide was
some kind of guidance that's the way my
astrology is set up so i monetize that
in terms of
doing astrological counseling doing life
coaching if you will
you know every once in a while uh
probably even happened to you a number
of times i know it did when you were a
kid
the business says people get confused or
something happens and
it's not part of their plan it's not
part of anything that they
are doing or believe in and they don't
know what's going on so they find out
about me somehow
these days it's not hard to find out
about me but
40 years ago i'm i was toiling in in the
backwoods
you know just sticking like you did i
dedicated myself
and i always ask myself what more can
what more can i learn how can i get
better
how can not so much be better than the
next guy because
that's a place where you and i probably
have a difference of opinion you know
you're you're you're involved in
developing yourself
in the context of competition i'm
developing myself and my clients in the
context of cooperation
and i am as well but i'm very
competitive but i still would like to
cooperate with you as well
well we're gonna do it okay it sounds
good wonderful sounds good
so so look for me you know i give you a
very funny story so one day i bring my
uh uh uh one of my analysts my senior
analyst and i bring my
director of finance i said i want you
guys to run a report for me they said
what report
and i've asked for a lot of weird
reports over the year but this one was
the ultimate weird report to them
i said i want you to take my top earners
who are making over put the number
quarter million then i said try it out
half the money try it at 100 000. try
that 50 000.
i want to report to see what sign makes
the most money
okay and i said i just and then the
report came back and said you got to be
kidding me
this sign makes the most money you know
and the way i ran it i ran it based on
months i didn't want it based on signs
you know because sign is a little bit
different
but there was a trend so the biggest
thing to me was
trends and then you know i started
looking at these trends i said why do
why why do april babies
do so well is it because they put a lot
of pressure on themselves to make sure
they get the job done in areas they work
in a safer stuff a different way and
virgos are perfectionists and why are
they why is it like they have the
perfect cut hair
everything and why is it that libras are
good at reasoning
and the way they work and why is it that
i've always gotten along with an
aquarius in my life i've never had a
moment that i've not gotten along with
an aquarius
except for maybe lucius prescott lucian
president him and i didn't get along but
everybody else i got along with
so the question i have for you is when
was the moment for you when you get in
because you know when you say strategy
if you say astrology to a christian
person they're like i don't believe in
it i don't even want to think about it i
don't even want to you know a lot of
religious people like don't even bring
it up to me
and some people are like i don't believe
in this it's fake it's not this it's
just a bunch of bs
but to me i've seen like 20 years i've
been following this stuff i've seen a
little bit
that there's something there what
formulas early on did you see ray
that you were kind of like wow this
makes a lot of sense was there like a
moment for you where you said there's a
lot of
trends that i'm noticing there may be
more credibility here than i thought
before i met this man
i think you know one word that happened
to me
um was when i um
got involved in being a radio producer
and interviewer
everything that i felt prior to that
had to do with me not really being good
enough to do any of that kind of stuff i
had that kind of opinion
and it wasn't even just that it was i
wasn't interested
i preferred the hands-on elbow elbow
bumps hugs and
contact with people but then i
discovered
uh you see from everything that i've
been told
i'm a sagittarius and that explains
something to me about
why i was always really feeling
weird about people being negative around
me
always pointing out all the things that
could go wrong and all that
so i started talking to people
in that same coffee house who were
associated
with the university of california in
berkeley
and they introduced me to some of these
people in radio and they said oh you're
the voice we need
and i said no no no i'm not and then i
found out that at the very
moment that this was happening there was
an eclipse happening
on the same degree that my uh
moon was i have a moon in leo uh
you and i get along on leo because
everything you told me about
yourself uh i have it right here you're
you're all intent purpose i think you're
leo rising
i know you got a jupiter in leo but we
won't go there yet because you want to
know more about
what that happened so that moment i
realized that i
all of my fears had been undercut and i
found myself in front of a microphone
interviewing some people that in in my
estimation
uh were above my station
but i walked in there and i just did
what i did because i didn't
care about all of that kind of stuff i
just cared about
talking about the truth and about the
positivity and about the direction
and about higher consciousness
spirituality religion
all that kind of stuff and astrology
then just kept on telling me day after
day
you're in the right place ray just give
up on
forget uh feeling uh comfortable or
inadequate and uh god
the cosmos the source or whatever put me
there
so i need to do uh what it is that feels
good to me
and i always felt really really good
when an idea of mind would
light up somebody's eyes and say oh gee
i never thought of that so that was
a way for me to continuously feel that
i i was doing the right thing it wasn't
me trying to run away from reality
i mean i i was brought up a catholic
although i never really practiced it so
much
um it was pretty pretty difficult to do
that um
especially the family that i had was
uh catholic but nobody ever went to
church
and everybody was in everybody else's
face about one thing or another so
my answer to that was hey mom i want to
go in the air force okay she said sure
day before that i asked to go in the boy
scout she said
said it was too dangerous boy scout no
but air force is fine
oh camping out in the woods like that
that's dangerous man
but can you go in air force
so keep going i'm listening well that
that's basically
that's basically is taking me back to
the psychology of this guy who
was in the military did you have an
epiphany did you have a moment where
you're like
listen because to me i'm not solving for
and i think you are you are you aren't
as well maybe you may be meaning
uh you can 100 of the time guess what
someone's sign is and say well this is
what it is because
when you sit there and think about signs
you know like if i look at the
in my business and i'll say i have seven
cancers
they're earners okay different
background
one has a degree one doesn't have a
degree parents religion
you know upbringing that was there that
wasn't there
you know major setback in teens major
setback
in 20s you know uh then a bad
relationship
a bad you know betrayal you know
all of that religious beliefs all of
that stuff kind of
makes up who we are but the foundation
would you say the foundation is still
our sign based on where you believe as
somebody that's been doing this for 50
years what would you say would be the
foundation of
my dna my individual as who i am patrick
that david
well i'll give you i'll give you a
little bit of an insight to
the way i i talk to a person they ask
they're
coming to me with the same question
whether they actually ask it or not
i say look at the moment that um your
body takes a first breath
you got to understand you're not your
body your body is something a mother
made
and while it's in the womb it's a water
breathing creature
even has gills breathes drinks
works with amniotic fluid mother puts it
out into the room
can't breathe got a traumatic experience
already gets whacked on the bottom
goes like that well what comes in with
the breath
almost like a trojan horse that air
carries your spiritual dna
and that is the conf
that the the the way the solar system is
at the moment
and it comes into you uh into your body
that way
and the reason that that that is the
case for everybody
is because you know the moon goes around
the earth
and you have this uh was borrowed from
quantum physics
whole idea of the wave state of the moon
is its orbit
it makes uh the earth a yoke becomes the
womb of the solar system
and so everything that is going on in
the solar system is solar system
manifesting creating all kinds of
versions of itself
and that's because if you look at what
the uh
cosmologists have been saying for the
last 20 30 years
the cosmos seems to be attempting to
become aware of itself
and that means that it seems to be tuned
fine-tuned to create life
so it has a sense of being alive
so if if the cosmos is alive in that way
the solar system is alive in that way
because it's a part of it
so the solar system is comprised of the
sun
and the sun is 99.86 percent of the mass
of the solar system
so that means a very very small amount
for all the rest of it
so the sun is the creator if you will or
the animator
and the planets are like the genes
they're like the
organs of the solar system so the solar
system is you
at the time you were born the solar
system becomes you
and me when me but it's the same solar
system
produce the same sun in the sky when you
were born i was born
so when people start talking about this
woo-woo stuff
we're all one there is a cosmological
reality to that
so the foundation is
when you take your first breath that
path you're on
whatever is rising so you've been on
this path of leo rising
you've been challenging yourself from
the day you were born
and in your experiences coming out of
iran
and in the whole idea of being a refugee
and so forth what you saw in those years
from
7 to 12 13 and 14.
man you know you were not
really satisfied with that's good you
are upset
and you took that upset and decided
i'm getting out of there and i'm gonna
find a way out of there
and around 10 or 12 the whole
circumstance
arrives total confusion on your part as
to what was happening
all of a sudden you found yourself in
the united states
and you looked at the united states and
you heard what they were saying and said
you can be anybody you want here
you said that's for me i i know what i
want to be
because i know what i have been and i
have been lost and poor
and angry no more nobody's going to push
me around ever again
and on top of that i've got something to
offer
and i want to work to serve and help
people that's my whole deal
i'm here to help people and the only way
i can do that according to your chart
is to learn and learn and learn and i
can't
at the time when you started thinking
this way i can't afford to go to
university anymore
well okay i'll bring them to me i'll
bring
these teachers to me rather than me
having to pay bucks
all kinds of money to just go hear what
i think i already know
so that's a short version of
how your your path is going now you know
i'm october 18th i'm a libra
i was born october 18th october 18 1978.
the sun is in the last 10 degrees of
libra and what follows that is one two
three
four planets in scorpio
the investigator the guy is going to get
into and find out what makes it all
tick i want to know why this works
let's understand it not only that
but i hope that it changes
my financial situation what i learned
or it can change my values it can can
even i
i i even want to believe in something
believe it or not i want to believe in
so please give me something to believe
in
and the end result was i believe in me
that's the driver but to me that you are
is an aspect of this thing called the
cosmos which is
what's called god if you want to call it
something
you know there's all kinds of concepts
of god among
um people of the world you can go from
islam to buddhism you can go from
buddhism
to you name it right
but what you have is nobody really know
um but you end up having to feel it
and in your case you know the whole
business
of how you you were able to transcend
things was because of
the way that you felt about your family
background and upbringing and everything
you were hit 24
5 6 and you were unhappy
clearly about how your mom and dad were
doing whatever they were doing and all
the experiences and you're upset
so you said okay i'm gonna get out of
this and i'm gonna develop
myself so i mean
i don't know where you want to go from
there but
i mean it's like you you you
you uh psychoanalyzed all of that
right do you believe in god yourself are
you someone who believes in god
well i'm looking at the sky and i'm
saying to myself that's the fabric of
god
there was a creator like a creator that
put all this together you know
well i mean uh that creator is still
creating and that creator is the cosmos
and you are a part of the cosmos so at
the deepest level
you're an aspect of god
but the god of the christians and the
islam and judaism is too small
it's too vindictive it's too human
you know you read in the bible that
we are made in the image of god
the reality i believe is that
christians have created they've created
it's their imagination of what it is and
i think that's wonderful
but it is too human it's it's too
vindictive it wants to punish you if you
do something wrong and so forth
there's nothing about learning except to
obey obey obey obey
now for you know ten thousand years
uh saturn in the sky was considered to
be
um the furthest cell planes you could
see with the naked eye in those ten
thousand years
these kinds of authoritarian points of
view
whether it's religion spirituality
or politics it's a top down the best
example is the pharaoh
people in those days lived hardly ever
past 40 45 in
ancient by that time and the pharaoh was
supposed to be a god that fell
from the sky to help humanity and
humanity in return was supposed to
provide him a trip back to the sky
well that's what the pyramid was for and
people
were dedicated to building that pyramid
for
when the pharaoh pharaoh dies puts in
the sarcophagus in the king's chamber
there is a shaft of light that comes
from an opening that's
treated replaced where a certain star in
some cases you know could be deneb or
any other kind of star but this
specific star
that was supposed to then hit that
sarcophagus and bring the pharaoh back
to
his position as a star in the cosmos so
we have all kinds of ideas and fantasies
and i
uh stories about why we're hearing what
we're supposed to do
so what i found in astrology is that's
the closest thing i've ever seen
that explains how god works
so i look i look at uh i look at the the
pattern
of the solar system the
spiritual dna and each of these planets
you know have a specific function
you know um mercury for instance oh
i want to go back just for a moment to
what you said about all these cancers
you have
you know why you have them why they have
this powerful thing called
image making power imagination there are
bonkers on the inside you never know
what you're going to come up with
but god sometimes the stuff that comes
up boy
you monetize that in an instant boom
there it is
you don't have to go through development
cancer
is ruled by the moon and the moon is the
development the
internals process of developing who you
are so these guys
are are really always popping out
something that could grow
you know and some of it needs more
watering than others they're nurturers
they will take care of each other
they'll
take care of anybody's working with them
uh
they're fine great you guys uh people in
in that respect
so so going back to what you just said
because you just took me to hold it from
the
conversation i got a bunch of other
things i want to follow up on but
uh so so do do you tie yourself to a
denomination just are you would you say
you know i consider myself
non-denomination atheist
agnostic catholic or no i i
i believe more in the zodiac than i
believe in a god
well i i i believe in the zodiac
and i am a buddhist okay okay so
and by the way i always say if i wasn't
a christian i'd be a buddhist
if i wasn't a christian yeah i always
say if i wasn't a christian
i would be a buddhist so then this takes
me to the next part because
i think it's fair to say did you
actually end up going to uc berkeley or
you just were by the coffee shop around
uc berkeley
oh it's just around the coffee shop
right they got it well it's far down
into the art in the air force
okay got it so you know i think it's
fair to say
the last 18 months have been very
divisive in america i had a friend of
mine that came yesterday one of my
advisors very good friend his
husband and wife were here and we had
lunch at this local
uh fish spot in boca and i said you guys
been around longer than i have i've only
been in america since november 28 1990
which is
30 years plus two months right so
you guys have been in america for a long
time and everything else with me for the
history of america is based on books
i've read
i've watched a debate between nixon and
kennedy i went and studied fdr
when i studied what happened but it's
not i wasn't
in the heat of the moment than following
it right and politics was probably not
nothing not something i was interested
in until the last 12 15 years
that's when i really said i want to know
more so
you know i have friends who are
democrats i have friends who are
republicans
i have friends who are independent i
have friends who are libertarians
and you sit down with a democrat
he can convince you that what he
believes in is 100
right you can sit down with a republican
he can convince you he's 100 right
you can sit down with an independent she
can convince you she's 100 right
same with a libertarian how much is of
this
is the truth or your truth
based on your wiring your zodiac i don't
know if you know what i'm asking or not
like
oh does our zodiac sign and the way
we're born we automatically are
politically republican or democrat or
independent is there some
uh trends and patterns between those
well i mean you're asking if uh truth is
relative or not
you know relative truth i mean uh i
i am i am convinced that um
the solar system uh and astrology
uh are a very good way for people to
understand what is going on with them
and what their life is about and what
the best uh
best way for them to be is the astrology
uh
moment of birth uh creates this chart
you know
um and the point is that the chart does
not tell you
uh that you have to do this
you have free will you can either
develop yourself what the chart says is
this is the best way
this is if you do this in a way that is
clear
and increases your consciousness and
awareness and so forth
everything that you do will fall into
line and it's the best way for you to go
but people whether they're republicans
democrats
or independents or buddhists or
catholics
they're going to go according to how
they feel
and that is going to be determined by
the conditioning
of their first 14 years in their life
the conditioning that gives them an idea
of
who they are in a sense based on how
they either fit or don't fit
and what they're told they're going to
have to do and so forth
but you know the idea that you that
you're bringing up is that
every one of these people in one way or
another has found their way
to what they believe in according to how
they
are responding to the circumstances that
they develop
but there's so many different levels
that you that you that you haven't a
human
being you know everybody operates first
of all on the biological level
and gradually socially you become a
socio-cultural
character you're playing a participant
you get married you do these things
you have children and all that and then
all of a sudden some
not all of a sudden but through a
process of growth and development you
then become an individual who looks at
society and says
i'm going to get out of that section i'm
going to do this
and then beyond that you
become completely successful you make
tens of millions and billions of dollars
and
you still feel empty there's still
something
you need to do and that's where you
begin
to understand the concept of feeling
the divinity calling within you to god
but to me god is the cosmos we're living
in god we are a part of god we're a
thought of god these cosmologists of
today
are basically saying that
um the cosmos
um is a great thought
so i ask you that question for a reason
the reason why i ask that question is
because
so you know i uh i
like data i'm a big data guy data tells
a story
right if i pull up data i can learn a
lot about anything
data if i'm running a business say i'm
uh
selling uh alcohol okay run my
dates on what day i sell what the most
and then i'll say okay i see trend
december
such and such wow people drink a lot on
thanksgiving day and you know stats
showing that
thanksgiving eve is the the highest
drinking
day of the the year and by the way
that's actually factual statement and
research i've seen right so okay
so while you're talking i go online and
i say what are the most common zodiac
signs to believe in god
and what comes up is it says three
zodiac signs
who are most likely to become atheists
okay
capricorn virgo taurus okay
then i go and pull up to prepare for the
interview i'm like you know what i'm
curious
what zodiac sign have we had the most
presidents with used to be 5'5 i'm sure
you know this now biden made it six
five scorpions not at the top then you
got aquarius is at five
which is lincoln fdr harrison mckinley
then you got cancer capricorn leo libra
pisces tied at four
then he got gemini and sagittarius three
areas and virgo is two right and then
gemini's you got jfk bush senior and
trump all the same
interesting leos you got obama clinton
same
interesting so so i look at a lot of
data and
and you know i mean by the way there's
some crazy data that's been pulled up i
don't know like the data if you've done
research on this yourself cancers are
the most dangerous according to fbi data
shows that cancers are the most
frequently arrested of all signs and
their crimes are often most
more serious than others cancers right
you got tesla elon musk tom cruise robin
williams george michael
leos are most likely to hit the gym the
most twice as much as everybody else
leos are also the worst drivers they get
40 more speeding tickets than libras
except
this libra i guarantee you i got all
leo's beating and speeding tickets
that's a promise right there
right so i go into this you know the top
athletes are frequently aquarians you
know michael jordan you know
21 of top best athletes in all sports
aquarius number uh second place is
cancer 12
so again i can go on serial killers are
two signs
pisces and gemini i pull up all this
data and it tells you something
so how much of it is like is there that
much of
if you are a sign and how you are that's
going to dictate how you're going to be
i mean you know data can tell us a story
what are your thoughts about the data
that
links to different signs well the data
doesn't
tell anything about dictation
it tells about how people either were
able
to use their sun sign energy
for positive things or negative things
and the most serious negative things
usually come
out of experiences in the first 28 years
of a person's life
usually in the first 14 and the reason
for that
is that in those first 14 years of life
half of them is the development of the
ego
and the other half is the ego trying to
figure out how to feel about that
so there there you are you know um
in those in those uh in in your in your
situation
you you have the reason you do this is
you have uh something in virgo
called saturn and it's in the house of
what is valuable and what to you is
valuable is your analysis and your
breakdown
and you give some kind of structure as
to
what people are doing what kind of work
are they doing how are they
you're interested in all kinds of data
that's what virgo is like
very critically uh critical analysis
i mean you go up and down on data alone
but the idea also with astrology is you
have to be careful with that because
um take for instance the gemini's right
it was kennedy
and then there's you know trump a lot
trump whatever
he can't remember your favorite
president i thought he's your favorite
prize
a picture in the background of his uh he
was my favorite favorite president
uh
kennedy uh as a gemini
ha uh was not
like trump trump gemini
function is to confront conflict and
resolve it
but a gemini like trump will take
conflict and use it to separate and
split people up
to keep himself in power that's how
that's how he works that's how he gains
power he just turns people against each
other and that's
everything he ever did whereas kennedy
did the opposite
he did the gemini thing of bringing
people together and overcoming conflict
and trying to connect and communicate
and understand you know
first words out of his mouth
inauguration friends and foes alike
you know talking to everybody we're
going to connect and we're going to be
real and you can count on us
now you asked a little earlier all these
years that i've been here and you only
been here for 20
i saw i've seen this country decline
in very very slow serious way
for just the word organic food
what a mind-blowing thing that is i grew
up and there was nothing but
organic food there's al there was no
chemical
it was no big ad and we had a lot of
local farmers
and they didn't use pesticide because
they didn't exist
so they used the farmers almanacs they
used all kinds of things
but they did it organically and so forth
little by little
uh through all kinds of ways of
you know the agriculture department of
the united states the
the government itself and the school
system
discovering that by the time he got to
world war ii
didn't have enough healthy kids to make
soldiers out of so there was this
school lunch program that was put
together and
that made it necessary for uh have
enough surplus to be able to give it
to them so you end up with a lot of
energy going into putting chemicals
into the ground as a way of growing more
food and on and on it goes until now
you have to pay extra to not have food
with chemicals in it so that's only one
example the political thing
i mean the political parties uh uh
in the formation of the country there
were never there weren't any political
parties when they formed this country in
it never dawned on them so that's why
the electoral college is such a mess
because
they were thinking of all the states
being you know
bound together loosely by an agreement
to be part of the united states
and so they could have this vote and
they could do that but it was all about
slavery in the united states at the time
because slaves
in the slave states didn't have enough
population
voting population to be able to
win an election they were all in the
bigger cities and so forth
well the solution to that was the
electoral college where
they said okay you guys um are going to
get so many votes
and we're going to increase your
population by taking
every slave you have and counting it as
three-fifths of a person
now that that is that that is where it
all starts and comes from
and racism uh you know the country the
united states for instance is a cancer
right
now cancer is all about race but it
means
human race it means human race because
it's an astrological
thing of god if you will and human
beings have turned it into racism
because the uh what you said about
cancers
perfectly fits the united states our
behavior in this world
you know we're we're we have this bring
me
your poor your ground downtrodden and so
forth
and then you have a president like this
who does that so
cancer can be very viciously awful
mean and terrible and it can be also
very kind
wonderful and nurturing and it all
depends
upon what happens to that in the growing
up stages so a country has
an ego just person makes sense you know
some of the best leaders of my company
are cancers
like i mean and i'm not talking about
one or two a number of them are cancer
so
yeah so if you don't mind i wouldn't
like if you just go and say
here's the fabric of an aquarius here's
a fabric of a pisces because
i watched that video you had with cut
and i watched it a few times because
you know girl comes in and she smiles at
you ha ha you're like oh
are you pisces why fish teeth fish you
have it
so let me see your ear and then you
looked at the ear like your ears are
poking you're going to be
you know and let me see this can you
stand or let me see your hands turn your
hands around
okay if you have something like this are
you oh you agree too much here let me
change the sign give the sign back this
is you
if you were that you wouldn't agree that
i mean you know the way you went back
and forth so it
it made it very technical like it didn't
even make it uh
easy to make an analysis so would you
mind taking a minute and just kind of
going through each sign and what the
commonalities amongst those signs are
well uh sure
okay um uh if
you know the makeup of of a person is
more than their sun sign but the sun
sign
in some way has a a physical
um kind of manifestation
and now take an aries person for
instance
um psychologically emotionally you're
gonna find them very
impulsive um and um
pretty hot tempered very easily
you know ticked off in some kind of a
way and
there you'll you when you look at them
almost everything about them is in their
head
you know i don't mean psychologically
but the shape of their head
the way that they talk is in their head
you know they don't use their hands so
much to do this way
in that way they use their head a lot
and and and their head is what aries
rules
if you're looking at astrology book and
say what part of the body does aries
rule
it rules ahead so you can tell
in aries generally speaking but it isn't
always true that
the the that they're going to look that
way because of being
airy sometimes they're a taurus but they
have an
aries rising and what was rising on the
eastern horizon
when they took their first breath that
also has an
effect on their physical appearance so
uh in aries rising may um be more
apparent
to you than or to anyone than the
the fact that they're taurus but the
aries energy is is pretty clear they're
impulsive
um they're
kind of bull-headed the way they handle
problems is
oh there's another brick wall to smash
instead of going under a rounder or
anything you know
they just go right at it uh a taurus on
the other hand
will look at that wall
for a half an hour and then
turn around and think about it turn
around look at that wall for another
half hour
and then decide eh i'll go around
a taurus is energy that
is based on the shoulders
you can find uh taurus as taurus
athletes
have huge necks there's a little head on
a big neck
you know the taurus part of a person
that taurus person
if you're dealing with let's say the
female
of the species tauruses are beautiful
they are fertile they are just
gorgeous lovely people
and it works that way for men too from
the perspective of their
their their their sense of solidity
their their
built like a block you know
the guys the ladies are built like an
hourglass
you know they're just all
very very sexually attractive sounds
like you've had some uh interesting
tauruses in your life
i'm married to one
[Laughter]
stage she's over there listening
no it's true it's true um taurus ladies
are very beautiful they're very fertile
they're they're they're very supportive
um and and the thing about it is that
you can't push them but once they make
up their mind a taurus person
you can see they're they're the
beginnings of libra
and the reason i'll tell you that is
this
the sign libra is ruled by venus
the sign taurus is ruled by venus
taurus guy or girl will say
i don't really care what people think of
me i'm going to do what i want to do the
way i want to do it at the time i want
to do it in the speed i want to do it
but i'm gonna do it so don't try and
stop me
libra on the other hand the venus that
rose there is like
well i am the social creature and i
have to sort of like not rock to bow
what my job is is to get be
friendly and happy with everybody else
because
i'm a salesman and i've got all this
stuff in scorpio so i want to be really
really nice to people
so that i can do the scorpio thing of
using them
to get myself advanced and i'll take
them along too
because that's part of the bargain i'm a
libra i have to be fair
so you care what people think about you
and on top of that with the leo rising
not only do you care about it but you
need it
you need people to like you you really
really do
because in in your chart after rise
after the rising sun and leo what comes
up is virgo
and virgo gets a little self-doubt and
says am i good enough
if people like you then you can say yeah
good enough
not only that but i'm better than good
enough because you got
anyway i could just go through your
whole chart you were like going straight
to it
yeah i know how so so if pisces i think
you went through
aries taurus libra you went into
uh cancer we spent some time on cancer
uh
what what can he say about aquarius what
i say about aquarius is
um they are
um they're in a whole
other universe they're living
in a a kind of consciousness that says
i i don't believe uh everything in that
little box you want me to live in
i want to live outside the box where
my job is to take everything that exists
and make something else out of it i want
to live
outside the box i want to be part of
something bigger than myself
i want to live on in a logical way
i don't really want to get hung up in a
bunch of emotional
morass about being angry about this or
the other
i want to be simply logical take care of
business
take care of the group rather than
myself as
an individual so aquarius is a is a we
kind of a person whereas a leo
is often a me kind of a person
right not that either one is right or
wrong versus the way they are
take fdr forensic is it aquarius and he
was all about the us of it all
and that's why he brought in the whole
concept of social security
because the figure had a responsibility
for everybody to
be able to at least have food on the
table and money to buy it
let's see what we got left so if we got
we covered uh
uh let's do scorpio and pisces
scorpio well
if you're uh as an example um
scorpio uh fundamentally emotionally is
an extremely private person
if you get in a relationship with a
scorpio
you best be aware of the fact that
they're not fully in it no matter what
it looks like
they protect themselves they are about
survival
and survival means it's their
responsibility
to be aware of what danger is involved
and so forth so a scorpio will
put a mannequin into a relationship
or a trial balloon or something like
that and eventually they'll get
more and more into it when they get
hungry enough because
you know the balloon is being fed the
mannequin is being fed all this love and
attention
and the scorpio is not getting it so
then they inching a little bit closer
and so forth
but they need relationships to grow
because scorpio follows libra
libra is about relationship you know
your relationship to everyone and
everything
and scorpio is the result of that
so a scorpio person is in the result
area
and they have to have relationship to
get results
you know that's really what
your scorpio energy is doing is trying
to get results from your relationships
so that it knows oh what is it in me
that needs to be strengthened right
and for for for all
your life it boils down to having
something to believe in believing in
higher
believing in god for instance whatever
dimension of god consciousness you might
want to
adopt and put your your your own psyche
into
um that that's that's
what your uh scorpio energy is really
trying to do
you're very helpful by the way as you're
going through it you know i
i went a little bit deeper to kind of
look at some more data
and different things came out like i'd
be curious you know if you have a sign
that
who are is there a linkage between the
happiest and the least happiest because
like right here says
capricorns have wandering eyes they're
always looking ares
makeup bulk of billionaires according to
forbes so forbes 400
the most billionaires are aries
interesting when you think about that
world leaders are often scorpios hence
six of them is ours right a german
astrologer named
fran ellsbett ebertine predicted
hitler's rise to power
based on his astrological chart in 1924.
i mean it's just
crazy to be able to say you know so
sagittarius are twice as likely to
become famous research conducted by
cartoon network that's a pretty credible
source
to conduct that research right you know
democrats believe in astrology more than
republicans do according to chapman
university which i've been to chapman
university
right democrats believe in astrology
more than republicans that's the
university you went to you went to
chapman
one of the best movie schools in america
schizophrenia is uh
signs aquarius and pisces both
teddy roosevelt and franklin roosevelt
believed heavily into astrology
top money makers according to career
builder scorpio leo
cancer taurus lois earners aquarians
capricorns
pisces have the darkest thoughts studied
by perceptual and motor skills gemini
switch jobs often
reagan hired an astrologer a republican
president
hero to republicans hires in astrologers
the scorpions are considered the sexiest
sign i mean
you know again like i tell you i'm a
dated guy but when you think about it
um do you have some things where you
notice you know
this sign is the most content this signs
the happiest this signs the least
happiest
uh on how they live is there anything
that you've seen there
well you know the thing about statistics
is that that's just exactly what they
are
that's all that they are
there's no one sign that is designed to
be the happiest
the propensity for happiness might be
greater
in one sign than another but it doesn't
mean
that that sign will always be considered
that way
but at the same time all the statistics
bring up that
yeah these were all these all these uh
pisces for instance
or were you know mentally deranged in
some kind of a way
right well um that's because
uh the danger of
spirituality if you will well
pisces function you know pisces is
a sign that has no
boundaries they are one with
the cosmos they're they're they're some
degree they're it's just like
uh they're they're all image
all imagination uh all higher
dimensions of awareness but the person
might
be afraid of that and
be afraid of it and be scared and do
things
because they're being spooked by it
but then there is enlightenment
where the pisces possibility for
enlightenment is such that their
oneness with the cosmos will leave them
in in a state of full awareness and so
they're
they're spiritually enlightened they're
beautiful kind and
wonderful people they're very very
sensitive but that very sensitivity is
what will
cause one to go down a very negative
path and another to go
a positive path to sensitivity level
there's no boundary that there can be
almost anything
when when i'm dealing with pisces it's
sometimes hard to find them
because they're they're so fluid
and the only place where there's
structure that
is providing they haven't lost all their
teeth i can tell the pisces by their
teeth
because their teeth i call them fish
teeth because
uh it's a pisces who has teeth that look
a certain way i can't describe
really how they really look but when i
see pisces teeth
i i i know them i know that they're
there
and by the way i saw her teeth what it
looked like and it does kind of
i know that teeth i just don't know how
to describe it either and i've seen that
teeth
you know many times in my life and now i
have to ask next time i ask and i say
are you pisces why me stop your teeth
because that's stuck in my head now so
what what sign have you noticed has been
the toughest to read for you over the
years
the toughest one to read yeah
scorpio scorpio is a tough story
yeah wow because no
no that they
um have a natural tendency
to uh hide
the animal that um you know in astrology
there's all these animals that
epitomize uh what the sign is about and
scorpion has two animals
i mean the scorpio two animals as a has
the scorpion
and the eagle now
the the scorpion operates this way um
it hides under a rock and if anything
comes close to it it comes out and takes
a
sting of it and moves back but always
hidden
and you can't get too close if you get
too close to them you don't know what
stun you you just jump
move right so they're hard to read in
terms of whether or not
they're going to accept you
as a non-threatening thing
whereas the eagle uh flies high in the
sky
sees the mouse down below and comes down
and just grabs that and that's it
there's no
there's no ifs ands or buts about it
just happens so
the difference between the two is
the the scorpion is the automatic stuff
you know they automatically attack
so they try to hide because they don't
want to attack because every time they
do they lose some of their energy i'll
give you a good example of how how
serious it is for the scorpion
it's the story of the scorpion and the
frog
now you're gonna like this story you
know
here's this lake here's this frog and
here's the scorpion
well the scorpion comes up to the lake
and realizes
it's got a long way to go it's got and
doesn't want to go all the way around
and it says to the frog hey you know you
can swim i can't
how about you give me a ride across the
way the frog looks at the scorpion and
says
you're out of your mind
you're a scorpion you're going to kill
me
you know scorpion says come on
you know look how do you think i'm
stupid
you'll be out there in the middle of the
lake i can't swim or sting you i'm gonna
drown
come on man use your head sure frog says
the well okay so they jump on there jump
on there
and the frog you know looking up saying
hey thanks a lot
miss scorpion i ain't no problem all of
a sudden zap sting
the frog look at his scorpion and says
what the hell is wrong with you
now we're all going to die scorpion said
sorry
you couldn't help it so you just have to
be a certain way
and in order for them to be a certain
way they have to hide that they are this
certain way
scorpions i just pulled up scorpions
bill gates a scorpion
ryan gosling leonardo dicaprio puff
daddy
you know i don't know if there's any uh
uh
correlation there uh with scorpions you
know
and gemini's you know gemini's some
interesting people are gemini's biggie
tupac
angelina jolie johnny depp john f
kennedy you know obviously trump
i think fdr was a marilyn monroe
you know i mean i can go on with
gemini's uh
are gemini is typically known for being
very
creative like artists do they have a
very big creative side to them
well i think what they're known for is
argumentation
they love to take the opposite side of
any are any conversation
i have a daughter that's a gemini and
and you're validating this
she's four years old it's it's a
constant
yeah right no matter what oh no do this
do this do that
but but but but but they do it just in
order to be able to exist
and they say no i mean they want you to
know
what they think so they'll go on and on
and once they start all
uh chatterbox the gemini chatterbox
that four-year-old of yours wait till
six seven eight nine and ten
rata tetra ten hold on too many words so
many words what do you want
lollipop you know they're going to give
you all the reasons in the world why
they should have this thing but they
won't tell you what it is
until at the end you get tired and say
okay okay all right
look i got to go out what what do you
want oh yeah dog or
sandwich or a hulk or kiss or something
like that
so gemini's are are like that they they
really are communicative they they love
reading
uh and their way of living is
widespread rather than deep they're very
curious you're you're for you
uh don't leave anything you not see
or touch anywhere near her
because she's going to pick it up look
at it toss it around and see what it can
do
very very it's so true right i mean i
can go on with you for a couple hours
i'd love to have dinner with somebody
like you or we can just talk offline
when once the craziness goes away
but any final thoughts or conclusions or
notes any final things that you have you
want to share with us before we wrap up
the interview
well i i think it's really important for
people to
um try to rise
above uh the social cultural
conditioning of the
first 28 years of their life if you want
if you will
because in the first 28 years of your
life you know you're living
uh in a cultural cocoon in one
fashion or another even though you
change cultures here and there
you're still you know um you get born
and you
crawl into this cocoon and uh
or some sometime around 28 yeah
yeah you have to say wait a minute i
have to reconstruct myself
so for me um
it's important for people to use
astrology for
for it for what it's worth uh it's a
guide
it is not a directive you know i
i see astrology now more
from a position of being transpersonal
it's not so much about you succeeding or
not succeeding
it's about being the best you that you
can be
and for some people that might mean
remaining in poverty
not mean that they shouldn't uh try to
get out of it
and all that but they need to learn how
to work with it
you have to learn to work with what
you're given right
so um i i really think that
uh in the coming years uh
as far as the planet is concerned uh
people need to be
more conscious of the fact that your
environment is you
and as human beings we need to be more
conscious
of how we interact with the planet
because i think it was john lily of eli
lillian company who said back in the
80s or so humanity has become a virus
destroying its host and that has to
change
so the only way i can see that changing
is by becoming aware of the fact that
we're having this kind of effect on the
planet
and begin to be able to figure out how
to change ourselves within ourselves
to be able to be better at our
interaction with one another
and therefore also with the environment
itself because
in the final analysis you know uh the
latest report i've read
is we're headed toward the end of the
century
with a planet that may not be hospitable
let alone inhabitable
so we have opportunities to turn things
around and
that applies to each and every one of us
in our own in our own way
i know you uh patrick are doing what you
can
to help people get to a position of
having financial security
so that if that's what they need in
order to turn around and look at the
planet and treat it better
all more power to you
yeah you know i i uh i appreciate that
from your perspective i mean it sounded
like you may be running for senate
or or congress or office here can you
imagine
we get uh 2024 astrologists running for
you know office my name is ray kator i
endorse
this message and uh i'm gonna lead
the cancer of a nation july 4th of july
1776.
uh you know it would be a very
interesting campaign if you ever decided
to run i'd love to interview if you
wanted to run
this will be the place we'd introduce it
to the world
i wouldn't be the first astrologer did
that we had george washington
and thomas jefferson george washington
and thomas jefferson were astrologists
yeah they were very deep into astrology
they were deep into
all kinds of philosophical uh
reformation that was going on at the
time um and
and uh you know the though
the the system of government was based
upon astrological observations
the whole use of the eagle as the animal
was also because of the scorpionic
nature
that the eagle represents and the fact
that
elections in this country are on the
second uh tuesday
or the first tuesday of november means
that it's a scorpio time and it's time
to
eliminate the old and bring in the new
and so that's why those and the 20th
of january as the inauguration day is
the day that
the sun goes out of capricorn and
aquarius
yes it's a a
mission yeah it's all astrology
we should sit for a couple hours and we
can go through all of that
um and you could you could you know
yeah can you continue with that what
what else in the way america was founded
on has to do with zodiac because
that's a whole different thing that we
didn't talk about at the beginning
well no i thought probably you might do
that i didn't know you were going to do
the statistic thing but
um yeah they're they're there's
so far so far you said the following you
said first tuesday
november 3rd uh scorpio
okay because it's the old and the new
you said january 20th
inauguration because capricorn to
aquarius
right and then you said the uh what was
the other one you said you said another
date
um that you gave
which one was it did you give two of
them only well again yeah you only gave
those two
um but uh uh the the idea of the
the structure of the government you know
uh you have
two houses you have the senate and the
house of representatives right
that was a compromise but it's gemini
it's like taking the concept of gemini
communication
uh between uh the lower classes
the house of representatives and the
upper class
the senators and the reason for class
differentiation there is because
it was taking the house of lords in the
house of commons
in britain and bringing
them into a new dimension with the house
of representatives in the senate to
signify the idea of communication
between classes that would determine
the form and shape of the government and
so
the the astrological idea
behind the
presidency of of of the country uh
is out of a uh long-time
long-term 30-year relationship that the
colonists had with the iroquois indians
the iroquois indian group
had a a democratic setup
and so franklin i think it was
and jefferson talked to them along with
with uh washington about how
how we should set up our government
constitution
and they said well um you you need to
have
um your chief chosen by a council of
elders
so that became you know the the congress
i mean this is this is fascinating stuff
like i said we we need we need more time
together
then around me uh somehow we figure out
to make this happen
uh once this uh craziness goes away
we need more than an hour together here
i really enjoyed this
ray where can people find you if they
want to find you what's the best place
for people to find you
best place uh you can go to astrological
perspectives
on on the internet www you know all of
that
yep we'll put that link below
news.net.com
uh that's probably the easiest way i
also have an email if you can
sure that would be astro for astrology
astro ray at gmail
easy we're gonna put both of those below
for people to find you if they have any
questions
uh a brace for impact you're about to
get some emails
uh astro ray gmail.com
ray thank you so much for your time i
really enjoyed it patrick
it's been my pleasure i really enjoy
hanging out with you like this
been great likewise take care bye-bye so
did he get you right meaning your sign
whatever your sign is did he get you
right pisces capricorn cancer whatever
it may be
and do you believe in zodiac signs stats
say one third of america believes in it
do you
uh and thoughts comment below another
interview i think you may enjoy as well
as ron white ron white has a system
for remembering all presidents
remembering words and his system is
duplicatable where you can learn
if you've never watched my interview
with ron white click over here
to watch my interview with ron white
thanks for watching everybody take care
bye
[Music]
you